CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
We're going to let
capital D denote
the portion of the solid sphere
of radius 1 that's centered at
(0, 0, 1), which also lies
about the plane z equal 1.
And then I'd like us to
first supply the limits for D
in spherical coordinates.
In other words, I want you
to determine the values
for rho, theta, and phi
that will give us all of D.
And then, I would
like us to just set up
the integral for the average
distance of a point in D
from the origin.
So there are two
parts to this problem.
The first is to determine what
values of rho, theta, and phi
describe this solid
region D. And then second
is just set up the integral for
the average distance of a point
in that region from the origin.
So why don't you pause
the video, work on those,
and then when you're
ready to see my solutions,
you can bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
Well, I would say from looking
at this problem, actually part
a is potentially a little bit
more hazardous for some of us
than part b.
Once we know the
bounds that describe D,
it's not too hard to
set up this integral.
So the hard part
of this problem is
understanding how to write this
solid region D in spherical
coordinates.
But it's actually really
not that hard either,
so I'm going to try and take us
through it in a reasonable way.
So the first thing:
I'm going to draw
a very rough picture
of the region
so we understand
what it looks like.
So in order to do part a.
And if you did not do
this, I would highly
recommend that next time you
encounter such a problem,
you begin by drawing
yourself a picture.
Even if it's not
a great picture,
it will give you some intuition
about what's happening.
So let me first draw the axes.
And ultimately
what I have-- say,
here is the point (0, 0, 1).
I have a sphere that's
looking-- in the zy-plane,
it looks something like this.
And so it has this depth here.
And that's the solid sphere
I want to be considering.
And then I'm going to be
removing the bottom half.
I'm only going to be looking
at the part that is above the z
equals 1 plane.
So actually it's going to be
all of the circular slices that
are in the top half, the upper
hemisphere of this sphere.
And so it's this
solid region there.
That's D.
And what I want to
do is to determine
rho and theta and phi.
Actually, the theta is
the easy one, right?
Because theta, at each value
here, I go all the way around
in the theta direction.
At any given height or radius,
I want to go all the way around
in the theta direction
from 0 to 2*pi.
So my theta bounds
are the easy ones.
I'm covering 0 to 2*pi in theta.
Because if I cut off the
back half of the sphere,
I want to only have a
restricted value of theta.
But because I'm covering
all the way around
and my restriction is
only in the bottom half,
my theta values haven't changed.
So theta is easy: 0 and 2*pi.
Now the harder ones are
going to be rho and phi.
But in fact, actually, phi
is not that hard either.
I notice phi is the
angle that I make
from the z-axis to
any given point.
So I notice that I certainly
am including the point where
phi is 0, and then I'm going
all the way down to a point
out here, which is a 45
degree angle with the z-axis.
So phi is also easy.
It's actually just
between 0 and pi over 4.
And the rho will be the
slightly harder part.
So that's really the
only really tricky part
in this problem is
determining the rho value.
Now, the rho value, to
get the outer boundary,
we'll look at that part first.
Well, the boundary
of this sphere
here has a certain equation
in x, y, and z that we know,
right?
It's x squared plus y squared
plus the quantity z minus 1
squared equals 1.
I mean, that's just the
equation for a sphere of radius
1 centered at (0, 0, 1).
So I'm going to write
that here, and we're
going to show how we
can manipulate that.
Right?
x squared plus y
squared is r squared.
r squared is rho squared
sine squared phi.
So I can replace this by rho
squared sine squared phi.
If you didn't know
that immediately,
you could make the
substitution for x and y
in spherical coordinates,
and it simplifies to this.
So either way, if you didn't
know r squared was this,
you can get it from just
doing the substitution.
And then z is going
to be rho cosine phi.
So here, I'm going to have
a rho cosine phi minus 1
quantity squared equals 1.
This, in the
spherical coordinates,
is describing the boundary
of this entire sphere, right?
And so I can actually
simplify this.
It's not too hard.
If I square this, I get
a little cancellation.
And then because I
want my rho to be-- I'm
assuming in this region,
rho is greater than 0--
I can do a little
simplification.
I come up with the fact that
rho is equal to 2 cosine phi.
And let's describe
exactly where that is.
That's the entire boundary
of this entire sphere
is described by rho is
equal to 2 cosine phi.
And so I want to think about
what my bounds are for rho.
Actually, I'm going to grab
a piece of colored chalk.
If I start at the origin,
I think about what is rho?
So say this is a point on
the boundary of the sphere.
I am going to start my
rho value-- whatever
it is when it hits
the plane z equals 1--
and I'm going to
stop it when it hits
the boundary of this sphere.
So my outer boundary for rho
is going to be this value.
It's going to be
determined by phi, right?
And now I have to determine
my inner boundary, right?
And my inner boundary is
actually quite simple.
It's a very simple
geometric thing.
And so my inner boundary
deals with the fact
that if this is my
plane z equals 1,
and I look at this
triangle I make right here.
This angle down here,
the bottom angle is phi,
and this is a right angle, and
the rho value I'm interested in
is this hypotenuse, right?
I need to figure out what the
length of this is right here.
And you can see it right
away from just the fact
that phi is this angle here,
you get rho is secant phi.
So the bottom boundary comes
from just simple geometry.
You get this length is 1 here.
So you get rho is equal
to secant phi, right?
This length here is
1, this is the rho
I'm interested in--
the blue part here--
and so rho is equal to secant
phi is the lower bound.
And it's equal to 2 cosine
phi at the upper bound, OK?
And the thing I want
to be careful of
is I'm not supposed to
include-- it won't matter
for the integral-- but I'm not
supposed to include the plane.
Let me write this,
and make sure.
Rho is going to be
greater than secant phi
and it's going to be less
than or equal to 2 cosine phi,
right?
Right?
So let me double-check and make
sure I didn't make a geometry
mistake here, just to be sure.
This picture tells
me that cosine phi
is equal to 1 over rho.
That's good.
So rho is equal to
1 over cosine phi.
So I get secant phi there.
So my rho values start
at the secant phi length
and they go to the
2 cosine phi length.
I know maybe I'm beating
a dead horse here,
but I want to make sure
we understand where
the rho values are coming from.
So actually, I have all
the bounds I need now.
I have the theta bounds,
and I have the phi bounds,
and the rho bounds.
Now you notice
that theta and phi
don't depend on the
other variables,
but rho depends on phi.
So we're going to have
to integrate that first.
So now we can deal with part b.
Part b-- let's come back
over and remind ourselves
what it said-- said
set up the integral
for the average distance of
a point in D from the origin.
So I'm taking the average
value of a function.
What is that function
I'm averaging?
How do I find the
distance from the origin?
Well, the distance
from the origin
is a great function to have
in spherical coordinates,
because it's just rho.
So the function I'm
supposed to average over
is the function rho.
In spherical coordinates,
that's the function.
So let me write down what
we're going to have here.
So in part b, the
average distance
is going to equal 1
divided by the volume of D
times the triple integral over
D of the function rho dV, OK?
So now I have to write dV in
the spherical coordinates,
and I have to write D in the
spherical coordinates bounds.
And then I know I have to
figure out the volume of D.
So we're going to figure
out each of these things,
and then we'll be done.
All right.
So first, what is
the volume of D?
Well, the volume of D, let's
think about what it is.
It's a sphere of radius 1.
And so the volume of a sphere
of radius 1 is 4/3 pi r cubed.
And I want half of that.
So I want 2/3.
Since my radius is 1, I
just have to do 2/3 pi.
So the first part is
1 divided by 2/3 pi.
That's the volume of a
half-sphere of radius 1.
And now let's integrate.
I'll leave a little
space to write my bounds.
I'm going to write
the bounds last,
after I have everything
in order over here.
dV is rho squared sine
phi d rho d theta d phi.
So I'm going to end up with
a rho cubed sine phi d rho d
theta d phi, right?
The dV gave me an extra
rho squared and a sine phi.
That whole part is dV.
And then I keep one
rho from the fact
that the distance
function is rho.
And so I get a rho cubed there.
So hopefully that makes sense.
Now for d rho, I know the bounds
are secant phi to 2 cosine phi.
For d theta, my
bounds are 0 to 2 pi.
And for d phi, my bounds
were 0 to pi over 4.
I didn't make you evaluate it,
I'm just making you set it up.
That actually is the solution
we wanted for part b.
I wanted to average the
distance from any point in D
to the origin.
So I just took the average
value of the function rho
over that region D. And so
that's how you finish that up.
And so in this
problem, basically we
want you to get really
familiar with how
to do some things in these
spherical coordinates, which
are sometimes a
little hard to do.
But if you noticed, what we were
doing in trying to figure out
the bounds-- in particular,
trying to figure out rho--
we took what we
knew in the x-, y-,
z-coordinates about
certain relationships,
and then we replaced the x-, y-,
z-values by the values in terms
of rho and theta and phi, and
you can simplify to figure out
the relationships you have
between rho and theta and phi
for the boundary value.
So that was one of the
techniques we were using there.
And hopefully, the geometric
understanding of why these
angles go from 0 to 2*pi
and 0 to pi over 4 is clear.
And actually, the
fact that this is rho
equals 2 cosine phi
should remind you
of the two-dimensional case
where you had some problem
like r equals 2 cosine theta.
And that drew a circle
off-center from the origin.
It's the analogous
thing happening here.
Maybe I should stop there
before I say too many things.
But again, the object
of this was just
to get really comfortable
with spherical coordinates,
and I hope it's helped you.
I'll stop there.